you
hello and welcome to the 11th machine
learning pattern recognition for use
with algorithmic automatic trading and
with sawsan Forex so where we left off
we were just basically looking at the
most recent pattern in our data and
looking at all the previous patterns in
the data and showing the similarity and
predicting the outcome now what we need
to do now that we've done this right are
clearly at least visually looking at our
pattern recognition it works pretty well
I mean it's not the best but it works so
we know the pattern recognition works so
we're done now we want to know and at
least begin to figure out does this even
matter alright so we've done pattern
recognition now we need to go back in
time and act as if we were running this
in reality so the way that we're going
to do this and really recognize new very
or new patterns and then see if that
actually works so what we need to do is
we can leave this stuff up here but
first let's cut and cut this out because
this will be the reason why we want to
cut this is this is going to change as
time goes on and I'll explain as we go
so so we cut this and let's just go all
the way to the bottom of the script
generally when you write programs all
the functions get defined at the top any
global variables get defined at the top
and then the actual like loop so to
speak the main loop is all done at the
bottom so let's come down here and let's
paste that stuff that we just made now
the next thing we need to do is
basically we want to run through this
data as if it was new data so we don't
want to load all of the data at the same
time so each time we want to add one
plot to the data and then run through
and be like ok did we know any similar
patterns to this current most recent
quote-unquote pattern and go from there
so the way that we're going to do this
is with a while loop and then a couple
of things that we need to do first of
all we need let's define data length so
data length will be and the reason why
this is is we need to know where should
the while loop stop so the way we can do
this is with bid so don't forget bid is
just part of this numpy array that's
defined up here
so bid so how long is that bid array but
you can't just do length bit array
because you keep the length of an umpire
rate so but the way that you can get
sort of the length is you can do bid dot
shape and then 0 with element in that
array and that's going to return a
number that's going to be kind of
finicky funky number it'll be a number
and an elf or I believe what stands for
length but let's just convert back to an
integer done so now we have data length
will actually print now data length is
comma data length now the next thing we
want to do is where do we want to start
right there's no point well first of all
if you started at point number one there
would be no previous data and no way to
make a pattern on that data so since we
start at 30 really we must start 30 but
we're probably not going to find it well
we won't find any similar parents
because won't have anything to consider
so to what we'll say is where you know
like from the beginning to what point
are we going to consider basically is
what to what means so let's just say
we're going at least two what is the
100th point now what we need to do is
we'll make a while loop here so Wow to
what is less than data line what do we
want to do we want to do this basically
run the program so we'll tab that over
and if you don't know you can just
highlight everything literally hit tab
now that average line is considering the
entire array that's cheating so really
what we need to do is now we're just cut
this and we'll just say average line
equals average line : to what this will
only consider the data that we're
allowing it to consider now what it's
going to do is it'll make the arrays of
all the patterns it'll make all the
performance stuff and it's going to make
the pattern for recognition obviously it
makes them empty right now but then it
starts storing the patterns and each
time we add one data point it clears the
patterns and redoes them now efficiency
wise bad idea that's going to be very
hard on our processing especially as
data length gets longer you can work
around that
that
can be fixed very easily but for the
simplicity and also I don't mean to
spoon-feed everybody this epic machine
learning application either I'm just
trying to teach you guys machine
learning but just I'm pointing that out
as well that that is going to be a
problem area as you start to expand and
learn more patterns but it doesn't have
to be a problem area so keep that in
mind
now once we do this it's going to
basically just run this while loop well
first of all of this would running
infinitely so we also want to do - what
plus equals 1 and if it finds any
similarities right we have House in
greater than 40 if it does if anything
is found it will plot it up now the next
thing I want to do is just to make this
application stoppable otherwise it will
never stop and just continue running
through we're going to just say move on
we're going to create this variable
called move on and it's just going to be
a raw input and just kind of like a
pseudo input here and we're just going
to say press ENTER to continue and
literally if you press ENTER it will
continue now so save that and let's run
this and see how we're doing so we
should it should save everything store
it obviously it's found no pattern so
you can hit enter to continue it's found
no pattern let me just drag this up here
hit enter to continue found no pattern
it's probably not going to find any
patterns yet so just literally hit enter
and hold enter until we find a pattern
it might take a little bit to find its
first pattern so it was oh there we go
got a pattern so here we go
found a pattern similar plots it up for
us cool close out of this hit enter
again wait till we find another pattern
found another pattern this one really
goofy but found it nonetheless and
another pattern and sometimes I guys you
especially as you get deeper obviously a
very similar pattern plus one point is
going to be fairly similar right so once
you find a similar one chances are your
info loops I made it huge find a bunch
of them so anyway I want to close out of
this oh and as you can see it actually
found quite a few similar pattern
go away anyway so now we're back to
press any key to continue now that
brings up a point is it brought up a
bunch of similar patterns for that exact
one pattern so why we plot them on a
different chart makes kind of no sense
right so in the next video what I'm
going to show you guys is how to plot
them all up on the exact same graph so
we can view it all all the same charts
basically visually that way as we build
this back-testing we can see visually
how it is and then we can take it one
step further and plot that don't forget
we have a predicted outcome a percent
change so we can plot that percent
change as you can see like here for
example let me try and find the last
press ENTER to continue we had quite a
few anyway whatever okay I found it
pretty good outcome for that pattern
positive positive positive positive
positive positive positive positive
positive positive positive you get the
point positive Wow so with this pattern
that we found the predicted outcome is
positive and what we can do is press
literally plot those predicted outcomes
as well and then the next step is to
actually since we do know what the
future outcome was both on those
patterns and also in reality we can say
we can plot that and then we can find
out we can go to the next bit of data
and not really the next range of data
and we can find out where we wrong or
where we right so that's what we're
going to continue working towards and
getting closer and closer to finding out
whether or not this is even of any use
at all okay but no matter what you've
actually learned pattern recognition so
it's pretty cool so anyway as we as we
continue we'll be able to find out how
useful this is and then also we're going
to start getting pretty deep into some
questions of variables so anyway stuff
to look forward to as always thanks for
watching thank you for your support
subscriptions and until next time